معركه دون رابح مع خسارات وازنه على
الجبهتين هذا ما اظهرته سيناريوهات متعدده
تحاكي غزوا صينيه لتايوان الجزيره التي
تتمتع بحكم الذكي وتطالب الصين بالسعادتها
بالقوه اللازمه الامر بالتالي 24 سيناريو
اجراهم مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه
والدوليه في واشنطن استبعد جميع هذه
السيناريوهات خروج الصين منتصره من هكذا
حرب بل دفع الصين اثمانا هائله وبحسب
المحاكاه الحرب ستترك البحريه الصينيه في
حاله من الفوضى وتحطم جوهر قوتها البحريه
والبريه وستفقد الصين
155 طائره مقاتله
و138 سفينه كبيره وفقا تقرير خسارتها تمتد
لقواتها مع توقعات بمقتل حوالي 10,000 من
جنودها وا عشرات الالاف في خانه المدافعين
عن تايوان تقف الولايات المتحده مع
اليابان البلدان سيخسران عشرات السفن
البحريه ومئات الطائرات المقاتله وخصائر
بشريه بالالاف بحسب التقرير فمعظم
السيناريوهات تتوقع ان تفقد البحريه
الامريكيه حاملتي طائرات وما بين 10 الى
20 سفينه مقاتله كبيره فيما تقول التوقعات
ان نحو ثلاثه الاف ومئتين جندي امريكي
سيلقون مصرعهم خلال ثلاثه اسابيع من
القتال اين نحو نصف ما خسيرته في عقدين من
القتال في كل من العراق وافغانستان
اليابان ايضا خسائرها ليست بالقليله وفقا
المحاكاه اكثر من 100 طائره مقاتله و 26
سفينه حربيه بينما تتعرض القواعد العسكريه
الامريكيه على اراضيها لهجوم اذا حاله شلل
ستعديها
انا الثلاثه في حال حدوث الغزو الواسع
النطاق للجزيره البالغ عدد سكانها 24
مليون نسمه لكنه مستبعد وفق خبراء طبعا
فرغنا قيامها بعمليات توهل منتظمه في
المياه والمجال الجوي قربه ايوان الا ان
بكين لم تخاطر بهكذا مناوره معدومه
النتائج وتضر اقتصادها بشكل حائل
[موسيقى]